okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I think um
uh
oh all sorts of questions here hmm
let me see
uh
now the question here from Anne how does
sand form near the sea
well
Sanders crushed up Rock
and it's formed by Rock being crushed as
a result of of uh
being pounded by by ocean waves now the
question is that several questions uh
one is why why are there waves in the
ocean well if if you imagine so first
the thing that generates the waves in
the ocean is is primarily wind blowing
across the surface of the water well you
might wonder
if you just have this flat surface of
water you just have wind blowing across
it why does that make kind of uh waves
that kind of go up and down why does it
not just smoothly blow across the water
and uh uh well maybe not have any effect
on the water but why does it Bunch up
pieces of water in the way that it does
that's a somewhat uh it's an interesting
phenomenon and it relates to all sorts
of questions about how gases like air
work and how fluids like liquids like
water work
so I think a couple of a couple of
things to say
one thing to say is it's a general
feature of fluids like like air and
water that when they move quickly they
don't move in a smooth way so if you
imagine having uh water it's flowing
around an obstacle for example if the
water flows slowly around the obstacle
it just kind of smoothly slides around
the obstacle but if you make it flow
more quickly there's a phenomenon called
turbulence that happens whose Origins
are not completely well understood but
what happens is instead of the water
kind of smoothly sliding around it kind
of it there's too much momentum in the
water it makes it makes little Eddies
that form behind the obstacle in a very
complicated pattern and exactly what
causes that complicated pattern where
one can work it out on a computer with
taking the equations of fluid dynamics
and trying to see how they would
correspond how they would make what
kinds of patterns they would make you
can get some idea that'll make a
complicated pattern but the full story I
think I've talked about another time the
full story of how turbulence works is
still not particularly well understood
it's something I've studied a bunch of
times over the last few decades and
there's a bunch of questions about sort
of where the randomness and turbulence
comes from and I like water or air
any kind of fluid flows rapidly past
something it will tend to produce this
complicated curled up kind of flow well
the same thing happens actually right in
the air that you often get turbulence
being formed people when you're flying
on a plane you know people will say it
might be bumpy because of turbulence
it's actually a rather particular kind
of turbulence that causes bumpiness in
planes at the altitudes they usually fly
at but it's a general feature of of the
motion of air in the atmosphere that
it's not just all going smoothly in One
Direction I mean if you say there's a
there's a wind it's a southernly wind or
something
um wind blowing from the south or
something like this or blowing from the
West whatever it is
you might think there would just be kind
of just uniform flow of air from that
direction but it isn't it blows and
gusts for example and those gusts are an
example of the result of well
essentially things like turbulence
happening in the air but the main point
is that you get instead of getting sort
of just a purely uniform flow of air you
get it in in bursts and gusts you get
more complicated patterns of of flow in
the air and so when that interacts with
the substance of water that's one thing
that makes the the water not just be
completely flat because it's being
driven by air that's that's had has
these more complicated emotions the
other big effect is that once you sort
of if you push down some water it will
uh you push it down in one place it will
be pushed up in another place you get
waves on water and when you just sort of
uh you you kind of you have something
some kind of um uh I don't know paddle
that's hitting the water in one place uh
just going hitting it you know
repeatedly what will happen is that will
push down the water in that place but
then that will cause water that the
water that got pushed down from that
place will show up in a different place
and you'll end up getting these waves on
the surface of the water and so
anyway the the combination of these
things the the waves on the subs of the
water being driven by kind of uh
complicated motions of the air in the
atmosphere the end result is that the
ocean will end up having uh sort of
complicated structure on the surface of
the ocean it'll have a complicated kind
of uh uh you you it won't just be a nice
smooth surface it'll be something that
looks uh kind of rough and um you see
that all the time and on the ocean and
once that gets the point of coming and
hitting rocks it will end up uh kind of
uh sort of repeatedly bashing the rock
um in a kind of random way and that will
cause that that's what causes the rock
to kind of um be broken down eventually
into sand and I think what usually
happens is that um uh the initially a
big piece of rock that might have formed
um is uh
um
is comes is is broken into a peaceful
break off another piece will break off
and then either the water will keep
bashing those pieces of rock or the
pieces of rock will bash against each
other and they'll just get broken down
further and further
you know when when rock is formed there
are two basic ways that rock gets formed
igneous rock which is formed from molten
things like lava
um coming from the uh ultimately from
the from the liquid core of the earth
um and that solidifies into things like
granite and so on and then the
sedimentary rock which is essentially
pieces of um uh pieces of of um of sort
of mud and sediment and so on that
eventually get uh crushed together to
form Rock and sedimentary rock tends to
be softer than than igneous rock
um but both things get I I think okay
there's a question I don't mean yeah you
can get rock you can get sand from all
those kinds of rock and um uh but but in
in general sand is formed by the mo by
the action of water
um on uh on rock at at ashore
um
so that's a a and once you when you see
Sam
there'll be little particles of sand and
they are little little tiny pieces of
rock and they're usually all kinds of
different shapes and the way that sand
packs there's a lot of detail about uh
kind of how how well the sand will pack
together that depends on things like the
exact shape of the little pieces of rock
that get formed by um uh by by The Rock
being being sort of broken apart by the
action of water and then all kinds of
other things that happen with sand like
when you have if you try to make a sand
castle or something you know having
water
um in the sand makes the the little sand
uh pieces of sand stick together better
um than than otherwise because oh gosh
well
uh that
yeah that's a that's another whole story
about about how liquids and solids
interact but maybe we maybe for another
time
um
let's see other questions here
um
oh it's a question from Zayden here is
grammar invented or discovered
well first of all we have to say what is
grammar so grammar for human language
says
what way of arranging words
seems like it's correct
sentences in that language and what
doesn't so for example if I say in
English the cat sat on the mat I've got
the cat that's a noun phrase
sat is a verb
um on the mat is another noun phrase
if I and I could say the black cat that
would be an adjective qualifying the
noun and so in English we have various
grammatical rules like a typical
grammatical rule is that we'll go the
subject of a sentence the cat
and then we'll say uh well let me let me
do a sentence that's a little bit
simpler the cat ate the mouse ate the
fish
so
um then we have the cat as the object of
the sentence eight is a verb and then
the fish is the object of the verb the
thing the cat did and so in English the
grammatical structure of English is that
you form sentences by going subject verb
object other languages do it differently
for example in in Latin for instance
it's subject object verb the the verb
comes at the end of the sentence
um
let's see
could I do it in uh can I manage It
Felix is a cat and uh let's see I'm I
think I'm I think I'm not going to be
able to do retrieve real-time Latin from
50 something years ago
um but in a case in Latin it goes
subject object verb it's the typical
word order but in different human
languages there are different sort of
standard constructions for how you put
words together into sentences
and
for example if you look at the different
languages of the earth there are maybe 7
000 languages that are sort of still
extant
um in and somewhat in use around the
world uh there's some very big languages
and some very tiny languages
um but uh the subject object subject
verb object and subject object verb are
I think the most common construction
forms for the sentences uh when people
have done made artificial languages like
famously the Klingon language made for
Star Trek is an object subject verb
language if I remember correctly which
is a um which is something that doesn't
it's not it doesn't never occur among
all ordinary human languages but it's
certainly very rare but so grammar is
this way of describing the set of rules
that specify how given a collection of
words you put them together into valid
sentences of the language okay so now
the question is
uh is is that invented or discovered
well we typical speakers of a language
will just know oh this is the way that
you put these words together it's
something that um uh we all learn at a
pretty early age uh usually
it's sort of interesting if you if you
watch kids learn language they'll
typically learn things like nouns first
um or just simple sort of one word kinds
of constructs yes no things like that
um uh you know uh chair this that and
the other things that are just single
noun constructions or perhaps other
single word constructions then later on
one gets people uh learn grammar the
grammar of the particular language that
they're that they're speaking now now
one of the things that gets tricky is
that different languages have different
kinds of constructions in their grammars
like for example English has uh
determiners like V and a uh you know the
cat a cat
uh some languages don't have those and
for people who've learned a language
which doesn't have those it's often
really difficult to know how where do
you insert those words because those
words are just not something that one is
used to even thinking about as a kind of
way of thinking about how the world
works
in English we have some constructions
English is a pretty complicated language
and it has a pretty broad range of
constructions
um across that uh uh you know there are
other languages for example English has
plurals cats versus cat
um some languages don't distinguish the
singular and the plural there are
English for example doesn't have uh case
endings it doesn't Okay so for a verb
um
there'll be a a verb like I run present
tense Iran that's a past tense I was
running that's an imperfect tense
um I oh well run is is a as an
intransitive verb so I can't uh I can't
construct its passive very well you
can't say I was run so to speak you
could say I was eaten but you couldn't
say I was I was run and so so anyway
English has a a whole collection of
different uh tenses of verbs and those
tenses of verbs are either indicated by
additional words like I was running as
well as by markers and the words like uh
changing like adding things to the end
of the word and things like that
um so English has various mechanisms for
full run but uh future tense it's adding
an extra word to make that that thing so
so other languages will have other ways
of indicating for example tenses of
verbs like they'll just have markers at
the ends of the words they'll sometimes
I remember in ancient Greek uh the uh
the perfect tense I I have
um run is um uh is indicated by a a re
reduplication of the first letters of
the verb so all kinds of funky markers
that get used in different languages to
indicate different tenses
in addition in English
we there are things like we can say
um
uh
I gave the food to the cat
uh the the cat's food there are all
kinds of different ways in which a cat
can enter the sentence so to speak and
those can be thought of as different
cases of the word cat and for example
when the cat appears as the subject of a
verb of a of a sentence it's nominative
case when it occurs in the in the object
of a sentence it's accusative case in
English we don't distinguish those two
cases at least that I can think of it we
don't usually distinguish those two
cases we distinguish things like the
genitive case with a cat's apostrophe s
and so on and we distinguish things like
the dative case by saying things like to
the cat
um with extra words
but again there are other languages like
Latin as a good example where cases are
always distinguished by decorating the
end of the word
um and so the the whole diversity of
different kinds of things that happen in
different in different uh natural
languages about the ways that one
indicates kind of the role of words and
so on one of the confusing things is
that some of the tenses that exist in
English don't exist in other languages
some of the things I was mentioning
determinants Like A and B that don't
articles that don't exist in um uh that
exist in English don't exist in other
languages and so on so there are slight
differences between the kinds of the
inventory of expressive stuff that
exists in different languages
now in terms of this grammatical
structure
um
you know I think we all learn the
grammatical structure of the languages
that we are sort of initially taught
and
the question is
um
for each individual person they're kind
of learning they're discovering the
grammar of the language the syntax of
the language the way that the words get
put together into sentences because
they're hearing lots of examples and
they're one's realizing oh that's the
way it works I've I've heard an example
like that before I kind of that sounds
right that doesn't sound right
now by the way it's always interesting
that that kids when they make mistakes
of grammar usually make mistakes by
making the grammar more regular than it
is in the actual language in English
it's absolutely full of weird exceptions
where normally you can treat the grammar
in a kind of very modular way where you
just put together this piece of the
sentence that piece of the sentence that
piece of the sentence each one is
separate but it's in English there are
many many exceptions where that
modularity doesn't quite work and and
kids will often quote Make Mistakes by
making the grammar that they say more
modular than it actually is in the
language as the language is normally
spoken but given that one is trying to
sort of learn the grammar of a language
which is already being spoken by the
people that's something where you kind
of have to discover the the grammar each
individual person has to discover the
grammar and a linguist who's going to
visit some uh you know obscure place
in some obscure jungle somewhere
um and is you know recording some
language some local language and trying
to understand it they will have to
discover what the grammar of that
language is
now in terms of whether we in
uh you know what happened originally
when languages were getting formed so so
the languages that exist today uh
presumably have uh well it's not
completely clear whether they're all
derived from a single common ancestor I
mean we we believe that all of us humans
are ultimately derived from sort of a
single common ancestor it's not like uh
sort of the human species developed all
its features separately three times
around the world
um we know that some other things like
for example the idea of writing develops
what three five times around the world
apparently quite separately the idea of
language did it develop in one place did
it develop in multiple places we don't
know for sure we don't know whether
there was a single precursor language
that then split into the 7000 languages
we have today or whether language was
invented separately in different places
I think the general feature one General
feature of language is the following
thing language is very very linear in
the sense you say one word then you say
the next word then you say the next word
and so on it's sort of interesting that
other things one do does aren't
necessarily so linear if you're
arranging you know stones on the ground
you're arranging them in two-dimensional
array and that doesn't have that same do
this then this then this but the
sequentiality of language is sort of an
interesting feature not an obvious
feature it could be the case that if you
want to communicate that you would best
be just sort of arranging the stones in
some pattern and that's that pattern
represents the communication or you
could do what you know bees seem to do
of of coming back from their their
flights and doing these dancers that are
kind of different um uh different kind
of um well in that case patterns in
space and time
um you know there are different ways one
can imagine communicating but language
is this way of communicating that is
very sequentialized one thing then the
next then the next
one wonders and I know there are
theories to this effect that kind of the
notion of language as a way to sort of
explain things kind of followed the fact
that people discovered these sort of
procedures for things like making tools
where again they have a sequential
character to them and the way that
people normally do them you do this then
you do this then you do this kind of a
common feature of our experience that
it's quite there are many things that
are quite sequentialized do this to
understand this than this and that's a
that's a very basic feature of language
and that's a feature of the the kind of
the way that we construct grammar syntax
for language is we're saying these words
go together in the sequence by the way a
sort of footnote to this you can imagine
languages that particularly written
languages that are not in just uh one
dimension just laid out in sequence but
are arranged in some kind of
two-dimensional array for example
mathematics when it's written if you
write I don't know and integral sign for
example and you have limits to the
integral there's one at the bottom
there's one at the top that's no longer
a kind of sequential left to right
something most like language is left to
right sign language is the right to left
but it's no longer a sequential kind of
thing where you're just uh going from
one side to the other a mathematical
notation has a bunch of those things
like a matrix you'll have an array of
things which are just laid out in two
dimensions and so on
um that uh
uh but but human languages mostly are
quite sequential
um they sometimes when they're written
they'll have diacritical marks they'll
have various kinds of markings above
letters that change them and some
languages have much more elaborate kinds
of connections between different letters
and sort of slightly non-local kinds of
ways in which letters get joined
together perhaps even not one not the
letters next to each other but slightly
further away in the most obscure cases
most complicated cases cases that are
but by the way an incredible pain to
implement on a computer but cases which
when people were routinely writing these
languages with a pen you know
calligraphically were not difficult to
to think about doing
but I think so a question that one might
ask is back when language was first
being sort of constructed a couple
hundred thousand years ago or whatever
um maybe longer than that
um what did somebody you know did uh did
cave person OG sit down and say let's
try and figure out how to communicate
things let's construct a language let's
um uh you know let's figure out
um that it has this kind of um
grammatical structure
my guess is that's that's not what
happened my guess is that that language
kind of evolved by uh it being first
kind of what kids do you know a noun
type thing or or a single word type
thing and then sort of people wanted to
people said those two words together and
then that became something some kind of
little phrase and then and then it was
it sort of got more complicated than
that uh my guess is it's sort of uh
organically evolved and got little
pieces stuck onto it and then people
what tends to happen in in language in
the evolution of language is for example
common things that were multiple words
get smooshed together as a single word
like for example website back oh I don't
know 20 years ago you would always see
it written as web space site but now
you'll always see it written basically
as website one word and that's a common
Trend and language that word smooshed
together I know when when I write things
and I use kind of recently constructed
recently invented kinds of combinations
of words and people who are copy editing
stuff I write will say no the dictionary
says those are two separate words and I
always say they will smoosh together in
a few years I'm just going to be ahead
of the curve and smoosh them together
now
um but that's I think a typical thing
that happens is that language sort of
some aspects of language kind of
simplify and Crush down when they're
commonly used it's it's a little
surprising sometimes that there are sort
of turns of phrase that seem very
complicated they don't seem to be it
doesn't seem necessary that that it's as
complicated as that and yet they stay in
a language apparently forever
um and uh
but so my guess is that that in the
early history of language that there was
sort of a constructions were made and
then they were sort of smoothed down by
usage and maybe people if there was some
construct that had extra little pieces
in it that um you know you went uh you
know you had a word and then you went
blah blah blah at the end of the word
and or you went blah blah blah blah blah
to say how many sheep you had or
something like that and that just didn't
work very well because people couldn't
you know really remember very well how
many blah blah blahs you've had that
that would be something that would sort
of go extinct in the language and some
other mechanism that some somebody else
had invented would would sort of come to
life now obviously in in the history of
something like English there are folks
like Shakespeare who invented lots of
words that make it into into the English
language and uh there are even I've
invented some words that have have made
it into quite common use and that's
something that that happens at a gradual
rate if you if if you were just
inventing all new words then that's a
whole different story and people try to
invent artificial languages famous
example from the 1880s was Esperanto
which was a language which kind of had
words that were sort of rough
simplifications of common European
language words which and so when you
look at Esperanto it's kind of you can
vaguely tell what it might be saying
because you kind of recognize those
words as being a little bit like other
words that you might know from from
other languages but it's kind of a a big
ask to get people to say throughout the
whole language you know and use this
completely new language
now I will say that in human language
this idea of inventing languages I think
is is not a thing that is uh is not what
historically happened in the case of of
uh programming languages and
computational language it's absolutely
what happens
um it's you know much of my life has
consisted in trying to build our
computational language welcome language
to try and represent things in the world
computationally and that language is a
language that is very much invented and
it's grammar the way that one puts
together the the Primitive functions of
the language and so on that grammar is
100 invented now having said it's 100
invented I know from experience in other
things I built things that people
understand things people don't
understand and the goal in inventing it
is to have it be as sort of As Natural
for people as possible and so that then
has a certain feedback from the things
that are just the way that people tend
to do things the way human language
works the way that things seem familiar
to people so in that sense it's
something which is again extracted from
sort of the ambient experience that
people have in in the way that they
construct language now I have to say one
feature of computational language and
programming languages uh sort of
programming languages are are more kind
of directly tied into what a machine
should do computational language I see
as being more take the world as it is
and try and represent it computationally
in a way that also you can feed to a
machine but the original goal is to take
the way that humans think about things
and to have a sort of precise
computational representation of that but
in both cases the the grammar of the
language tends to be very uh kind of
very simple and structured so and it's
it's defined by a set of grammatical
rules so for example let's say you're
doing something with I don't know uh
plus signs and time signs so you would
say okay in the language you can have uh
blob plus blob where blob could be some
uh thing which itself has plus signs in
it or has time signs or whatever else
and you're always kind of recursively
defining you say a a sentence in the
language call it blob can be broken down
into blob plus blob blob times blob and
so on and at each and then you can
reapply that same rule blob can be blob
times blob so the The Blob plus blog
could be the first blob there could be
some blob something times something the
second blob could also be something
times something and so on so you have
this kind of recursive structure and
when you want to parse the language when
you you want to understand what the
language is saying you want to go from
that linear sequence a times B plus c
times D for example and you want to say
what does that quote mean what you do is
you make a tree that kind of reverses
that definition
specification that says you know blob
goes into blob plus blob you're going
from the plus and you're saying those
are those are sort of pieces of the of a
tree that eventually that that that that
that's part of the the rule that's that
goes blob goes to blob plus blob so when
you pass a language what you're doing is
you're trying to invert that sort of
recursive specification of language now
a question is well what kind of
recursive specifications can you
reasonably use in a language and the
answer is that this kind of very
structured recursive specification works
pretty well people are pretty funny
pretty easy to understand that if you
say well there are a bunch of exceptions
in this this one feature of that sort of
recursive definition is things are
context free in the sense that if you
can have LOB
could be a blob plus blob that's true of
a blob that occurs anywhere you're not
saying oh if that blob happens to occur
inside parentheses then you can no
longer do that decomposition it says
it's kind of context-free it's
independent of context you can have
these these rules for how you how you
kind of construct things on the grammar
apply independent of context and in
programming languages computational
language that's typically the way
they're constructed it's the way that's
easiest for the programmer to construct
them it also turns out to be the way
that's easiest for the users to
understand what is a valid piece of
syntax and what's not
um so and whenever in my experience in
doing language design whenever one
deviates from that context-free thing
that those are places where you get
people get confused at least can get
confused now one feature I will say in
in computational language programming
languages is when I say A times B plus c
times d
one of the questions is if I'm going to
make a sort of tree that says uh what
the structure of that is I have to know
the sort of order of operations thing
that times binds tighter than plus so a
times B is one blob and then the c times
D is another blob and those two blobs
are added together by the plus and that
idea of Precedence is one of the tricky
things in specifying a language because
without that precedence without knowing
that the times binds tighter than the
plus you wouldn't know how to how to
parse that that sentence so to speak you
wouldn't know how to uh how to decompose
that in into into sort of this tree-like
structure
and one of the things that does get a
little tricky is if you have a large
number of different operators like plus
and times and wedge and and Slash and
all this kind of stuff there's it can
get quite tricky what the Precedence of
those what the relative precedence of
those operators is another thing is
associativity of operators if I say a
plus b plus C plus d it doesn't really
matter how that groups it doesn't matter
whether it's you do a plus b first you
do c plus d first it doesn't matter
which in which order you you do the
operations in which how you how you put
parentheses in on the other hand if you
say a minus B minus C it absolutely does
matter because a minus B minus C if if
the B minus C has parentheses around it
there's a different result than if the a
minus B has parentheses around it
and usually in in in subtraction uh you
usually have left Association in the
sense that you group The a minus B first
and then you subtract a c from that and
if you have a minus t you subtract the D
from that
on the other hand trickier case if you
have a slash b c d
what exactly does that mean does that
mean you take the A and you divide by B
and then or do you divide the B by C
which gives a different result than
taking A over B all over C in which
direction does that associate
and I could keep going with with more
and more bizarre cases power as another
case if you do uh a to the power a wedge
B wedge C to represent Powers how do you
want that to associate
or
another example a little bit more
programming language specific is
something like a equals b equals c
so uh
you what you want to do there if you
left Associated that you would say a
equals B okay fine that means we set a
to B and the result of that is probably
going to be B
uh well that's a bit of a whoops because
what you actually want if you say a
equals b equals c is you probably want
everything to be set equal to C you want
B to be set equal to C and you want a to
be set equal to B which is now set equal
to C and so that's an example where you
have to right associate we have to put
parentheses in on the right hand side
not the left hand side and and some of
these things are very kind of
everybody's like oh well of course you
do that because they have an immediate
understanding of that and sometimes
those things like associativity and
precedence are not so obvious to people
and people get confused sometimes it's a
very painful thing for language
designers you know there are two
different choices of Precedence and
whichever one you choose there are going
to be cases where people get confused
um and it's it's very frustrating and in
modern times we're able to kind of patch
over that to some extent by using
various kinds of uh user interface
effects kind of hover effects that
indicate what grouping is happening what
grouping is implicitly being assumed so
that you can see if you're typing
something in oh that isn't quite the
right grouping so let me change that
before you type it in and just have it
be interpreted in the wrong way
but I think in the um
in the construction of human language
this idea of context Freedom this idea
that the the sub Clauses can be put any
way you want that it doesn't that you
know that when you have a a sub Clause
that has um uh that that puts an
adjective in front of a noun that you
can do that wherever the noun occurs
that and that it isn't just oh only in
these places where noun occurs
human language is also somewhat
context-free it has weird exceptions but
it is somewhat context free now human
language doesn't tend to allow you in in
programming languages in computational
language you can usually kind of go as
deep as you want uh you know it's it's
you as a programmer might not understand
it very well but you can go as deep as
you want so
um but in human language we don't tend
to do that I mean uh the cat was sat on
the mat which was uh made of this which
was or this which which did that blah
blah blah blah
and then that whole set of sub Clauses
about the cat
then say you say ate the fish so you've
gone very very deep in the subclauses
and then you come back up and you have a
verb you say ate the fish or whatever
um and um
in the um uh
we don't tend to we humans have a hard
time keeping track of subclauses that go
too deep maybe four times five times
that kind of depth is the maximum we go
to so there are sort of practical
limitations to do with how we can buffer
things up in our brains as we try and
understand language but in a first
approximation language is pretty pretty
human language is is reasonably close to
context-free and reasonably close to
allowing all these different sort of sub
pieces to be inserted wherever wherever
they can be so to speak and you know I I
think it's an interesting question
whether the
um
you know that there are
well
human language is is sometimes people
try and sort of by Fiat change like the
the writing system for human language it
is much less common that people sort of
uh are at all successful in changing
things like grammatical structure of
languages I mean sometimes people it's
like you know newspaper headlines
um at times have kind of uh redefined
some of the ways that uh are considered
to be appropriate grammar and and I
think that's had some effect anyway a
few few thoughts about that
interesting question
uh let's see
um
uh okay
several other questions about languages
here
um
Brady says I believe there exists a 13
letter language from a Pacific island do
you think a 10 letter language would be
useful since every word
uh would also be a base 10 number well
it's an amusing idea you know we always
have 26 letters in English
um and uh there are European languages a
few more letters a few less letters
um this question of sort of how you
break the words into letters this is a
not not every language I mean the
idiographic language is like Chinese
Japanese and well to Chinese has pure
sort of pictograms to represent
typically words or pieces of words
Japanese has multiple different systems
one sort of Chinese character like and
another more alphabetic like like
English
um but uh the um
this question of sort of how many
letters do you need well you don't
really need that many I mean you could
construct everything in principle in a
in a sort of binary code
um how many is convenient to have
um I'm not sure what the right answer to
that is I mean what one would like to
have be the case okay so here's a here's
a perhaps a relevant thing so the
question is when you see a letter e or
letter I does it always sound the same
and the answer is in English absolutely
not there are you know places where the
word e what the letter e will be
inserted and it says e and they're ones
where it's e and there are ones where I
don't know I I don't even know all the
cases there are all sorts of different
sounds that that letter can make now
there are languages which are and so
that means for example that spelling is
difficult in English
um that because you can't just say what
does this what sound does the word make
okay I know the sound the the the the
the the the vus sound is always a v so I
just have to put a v there when I spell
the word well actually pH could make a
verse sound in in some in some words Etc
et cetera et cetera so so you don't know
there isn't a unique correspondence
between the sound of the word and the
letter in the word
um and that's a that's a feature of
English and of course English had had
some real Horrors in its um spelling in
the past because there were times when
people said let's make the spelling
sort of record things about the meaning
of the word I think a famous example is
the word debt which is spelled which at
times in the past was just spelled
d-e-t-t for example but somebody had the
bright idea let's burn into this struck
into the spelling of the word something
that means something about the meaning
of the word and since in Latin the the
word for debt you know debt is a
debiture with a b
um somebody had the bright idea let's
put into the spelling of the word debt
in English a b now obviously people but
people weren't saying that b so it just
became this weird extra piece that was
put into the spelling of the word and
that in order to know how to spell the
word from it being spoken you just have
to know that fact
so in any case one thing that can happen
is languages I I believe Russian is an
example of this as a language which is
essentially phonetic that is if you know
how to say the word you know how to
spell the word
um not true in English that's why we can
have spelling bees in English because a
spelling bee will be rather trivial in a
language where all you have to do is
hear the word said and you can um and
you can then write down the spelling of
the word
um and you don't have to know anything
about the history of the word and and
the sort of origins of the word and all
those other kinds of things that
contribute to English spelling but so I
would think that there's a sort of a by
the time you've got a language with a
set of complicated sounds in it so so
you know when you when you have a word
there is it's spelling as as in written
language there's also it's phonetic
version as a sequence of phonemes so you
know we have in English or how many is
it
30 40 phonemes I'm not sure
um there's different kinds of sound
fragments from which our words are made
and those sound fragments aren't
necessarily single letters they may be
combinations of letters they may even in
some cases perhaps I'm not sure I don't
immediately have an example of this uh
well okay they're a weird
examples the word naive maybe does that
where where you have maybe not where you
have a single letter that can actually
be broken into multiple phonemes but
anyway there's a there's a fanatic
version of the word which is phoneme
number this phoneme map phoneme that and
and there is a notation for phonemes the
IPA the International Phonetic Alphabet
that has sort of somewhat based on the
English alphabet but it has you know
upside backwards ease and it has all
kinds of other letters that represent uh
kind of the sounds that get made in
different languages and the full
inventory I know maybe 100 or so sounds
that we humans get to make with our
vocal tract and sometimes there are
there are kind of funky sounds like
clicks and whistles and things like this
which uh uh are are sort of part of the
of the phonetic uh inventory of things
that can be used in languages so I would
kind of think that there is a certain
pressure to have more letters in a
language because then it becomes more
phonetic I mean given that you're using
multiple sounds and since we can make
those sounds with our vocal tracks why
not use them if we can make them why not
have sort of one letter per sound might
be a a more kind of rational way to set
these things up now obviously people
hadn't uh that kind of construction the
idea of let's construct a language that
didn't really happen that way and I
think you know the way that letters well
letters uh
were uh presumably there were actual
inventions of letters in their actual
people who figured out we want this
letter we want that letter you know
probably somebody invented the letter W
for example
um and uh I bet it's not known who that
was
um but uh
in um uh in these kinds of things that
that's a um uh you know those those
things have to get invented and I think
uh probably when you know when
typewriters and printing came in there
was that forced a certain amount of
standardization because like if you're
if you have a typewriter you have a
certain set of keys on the typewriter
printing you have a certain set of font
characters that you've made and so you
don't want something where oh well just
every so often people have this weird
extra letter like like in English the
word naive for example if you you know
when you see it written in very literary
kind of places or magazines and so on
the I will have a double dot on top of
it that represents it's um uh it's a
it's a differently sort of said I but
that kind of uh sort of pedantic writing
of something like that most of the time
you're just going to blow that away
because it's like I don't have an eye
with two dots on it on my keyboard I'm
just going to type an ordinary eye and
pretty soon all that stuff goes away way
I think it's something which which sort
of was interesting in in the early days
of things like texting and so on when a
lot of languages a lot of the kind of uh
elaborate markings that exist in an
extra letters that exist in some
languages to work there in texting and I
think for a while it looked like some of
those kinds of spelling and so on would
go extinct in some languages but as the
technology caught up uh they they came
back and I don't think they've they've
gone extinct in that way but you know
when it comes to the writing of
languages uh the number of you know
writing was independently invented maybe
five times or so and then the question
is if you've got a language
that was basically a spoken language how
does it get to be a written language in
the first place and the answer is
somebody
uh in some cases in more modern times
somebody just invents a way of writing
the language down I mean famously you
know it was a monk named Cyril I think
who uh uh did the Cyrillic alphabet that
gets used uh you know and
russian-speaking kinds of places and I
think the Armenian alphabet there's a
definite person that invented that and
so on and uh you know we we don't know
the person who invented the sort of
Phoenician alphabet that turned into our
English alphabet
um but uh the um
uh when when it comes to sort of a uh
some some sort of indigenous people
somewhere who didn't have a written
language or at least none that anybody
identifies as a written language then
somebody went in there some
anthropologists some linguist went in
there and they said well I'm hearing
these sounds let me write down let me
construct a written language uh for this
particular place and that's how almost
all of the 7 000 languages of that are
of the Earth the a largest fraction of
those that are uh were just spoken
languages and somebody just had to
invent the way of writing them down and
uh sometimes that was done better and
sometimes it was done worse but one
shouldn't I think deduce Too Much from
the way that these things are written
about sort of intrinsic features of
those languages because that was really
an add-on it tells you more about the
education of the linguists perhaps than
it does about the actual language itself
um
let's see
uh
oh boy
um
let's see
okay so RBS is asking kind of natural
programming language replace concrete
programming languages well so
one question is what can we just talk to
our computers and tell them what to do
and you know I've been deeply involved
in this issue and uh in you know
constructing wolfen Alpha which is a
natural language interface system and in
constructing uh uh the the kind of tools
for intelligent assistance where you
just use whatever you whatever comes
into your head whatever you think to
type
so the basic experience that we have is
for short utterances for a short
question for a short thing you want to
describe natural language Works quite
well when you have a bigger Longer
structured thing it's like you're
building a tower and if you just sort of
throw pieces of wood together at the
beginning you're not going to be able to
build a very tall tower in order to
build a tall tower you have to kind of
arrange things in a nice structured way
and in sort of a computational language
that has a structured language you can
absolutely build that Tower taller and
taller and you can make a program that's
one line two lines five lines ten a
hundred a thousand a million lines long
and it's still going to be something
that sort of hangs together coherently
and is is useful whereas if you try and
do that all with natural language it's
something where it uh you won't be able
to systematically keep building up that
Tower it'll be something where it's like
you keep on having to go back and say
what do I actually mean by that
foundational concept there and and uh
and it gets it gets difficult to do
now I think that one of the things we
found is that as I say it's really
powerful to mix kind of structured
computational language to get little
fragments of natural language so for
example in modern language it's pretty
common if you want to say uh what's the
distance well what's the um
uh I don't know make a map that shows
the path around I don't know European
capital cities with I don't know what
with with indicating each City by the
flag of the country or something
uh okay that was a reasonably easy thing
for me to describe but the thing that is
sort of realistically and reliably sort
of possible is something like countries
in Europe that's something where one can
realistically interpret that it's kind
of just one interpretation of that well
you can ask oh I don't know is Turkey in
Europe is Russia and Europe those kinds
of things there are details of meaning
but in terms of the the what is the
basic structure there that's the thing
that's fairly easy to describe and so
that will fragment is fairly easy to
deal with but then
uh and so what we find is you know in
Wilson language is just control equals
and you type some natural language and
then you resolve that it turns into some
precise thing that you can you can see
what it turns into and then you go on
and you build up your your more
structured thing on top of that resolved
what the natural language meant peace
and I think that's a pretty good way to
do things now we have this uh uh product
for both malfa notebook Edition uh where
where wolf malfa is a system where all
you have is a natural language you're
just asking questions purely in natural
language both mouth and notebook Edition
is kind of a hybrid situation where you
are sort of asking small questions in
natural language they're interpreted
into our symbolic language then the
result of the question is generated then
you can keep going and you can build up
this whole sort of notebook of uh of of
uh of of computations and that's kind of
the the compromise case between the
purely structured language and the pure
natural language case and it looks it
seems to be really quite quite nice and
quite uh very useful for certain kinds
of things uh particularly useful in all
sorts of educational settings data
science settings things like that where
you're kind of just each individual step
is something comparatively easy to
describe but as you build these steps up
you get something something uh more
sophisticated and in the sort of
mechanism by which this works every step
you build up you're kind of confirming
that step oh yes that's really what I
meant and then you build the whole thing
up and and it makes a makes something um
uh make something good there
let's see all kinds of questions all
kinds of questions about quantum
mechanics and things well let's see I
think we don't have time for more than
maybe one or two more
um
well okay there's a question from Aslan
about thoughts on languages from a
perspective of category Theory seems
like category Theory encompasses all of
math okay let's see if I can give you an
elementary uh version of what category
theory is
so
in math
there are different kinds of math one
does one does arithmetic deals with
numbers you know it's um it has
operations like addition and Etc but the
things what's dealing with their numbers
two three four whatever else
there's also algebra where you have
things like x's and y's and and um you
have operations that say factor a
polynomial or something like this that's
a different kind of area of math well
you might have geometry where you have
uh kind of um you know triangles and
squares and angles and things being
congruent to each other and things like
that each of these areas of mathematics
has kind of a a way of that it has
certain constructs in it which have
certain relations to each other
so for example
um you might
have
something where you say oh I can
transform every
oh I don't know what's a good example I
can
um take
every collection of numbers I have and
just say how many numbers are there in
that collection that's sort of a
transformation from any collection of
numbers to just the size of the of that
that collection something like that so
but
any case we can think of these areas of
mathematics as for example let's say in
arithmetic we might have operations we
might have numbers we might have um I
don't know maybe we'll take algebra we
might have things like um rational
expressions something over something we
might have polynomials we might have
individual variables things like this we
have all these different kinds of things
well
uh I never tried explaining this at a
monthly level before so so please um uh
uh I I'm and this is not a category
theory is one of these things that's in
kind of the the higher reaches of
abstract mathematics and it's um but but
let me let me keep going here so
basically the the idea is you have these
different kinds of things these
different kinds of objects in let's say
algebra or something and then you can
kind of think of what is the structure
of algebra oh it's a way of relating one
set of objects
to another set of objects and category
theory that kind of relation is called
amorphism and it's kind of it tells you
this set of objects uh is is sort of
related to this set of objects which
again can be related to another set of
objects and so on and so category Theory
tends to have these chains of relations
you know something f is something some
some objects X are related by amorphism
F to objects Y which are related by
morphism G to object Z and so on and you
get these kind of chains of relations
like that
um
one of the things so when you have those
chains of relations in when you think
about them in terms of computation you'd
say well okay I take the original set of
objects and then I apply some
computational operations some function
to those some computational function to
that original set of objects get another
set of objects I play something again I
get another set of objects so I've I've
done one computation then I've done
another computation
okay so in general when you do one
computation then another computation
there's absolutely no guarantee that
there's an easy computation that does
the equivalent of both of those together
in fact in many kinds of computations
there's this phenomenon that I kind of
uh developed called computational
irreducibility that basically says that
in general you can't Crush things down
if you've got one piece of a computation
then another then another then another
there's no fast way to figure out the
end results you have to just go through
all the steps and see what happens
but category theory has an assumption it
says well actually whenever you can go
operation F then operation G there's
another operation let's call it Q or
something which is the one step
operation that does f and g together
and you're not really distinguish the
the sort of the Q operation the super
operation from the do two operations
together there's a big assumption in
category Theory it's a big kind of
structural Foundation it's it's a a
thing called compositionality in
category theory is that essentially
assumption that that always works
we know that in general computation it
doesn't work so category theory is a
kind of an idealization of General
computation that says we're looking only
at those computations where there is
this kind of Jump Ahead jumping ahead
possibility
and and so
what we try and represent we try and use
category Theory to kind of represent
what's going on in math whenever what's
going on in math has this computational
irreducibility phenomenon which isn't a
very good fit for category Theory
category theory is putting put it this
sort of overlay on top of what's
happening in math that is uh kind of a
simplification that may be good for us
understanding what's going on so it's
similar you know I uh when you think
about I don't know gas molecules
bouncing around a room they do very
complicated things but when we say let's
let's look from a distance let's
aggregate all of that and just look at
the overall pressure of the gas and then
we have a simple gas law
something similar is happening with
category Theory that's sort of
underlying computational stuff that's
going on but you're only looking at the
sort of aggregated piece that's sort of
from a distance and that has these
simplifying properties that make it
easier for us to actually understand
what's going on in math
now okay having said all of that the um
uh
there are
ways okay so that's sort of the category
Theory schtick it's it's kind of this
this the superstructure that you can put
on top of math that kind of explains
structurally what's happening in in
different areas of math and with this
simplifying assumption that helps one
understand these things and one of the
important things about category theory
is because the even though the objects
one's dealing with in let's say
arithmetic geometry whatever very
different category Theory provides this
kind of structural overlay that lets one
translate kind of what's going on in one
area to what's going on in another area
you know it's it'll be a long story but
but um uh a big project that I did
earlier this year about metamathamatics
has to do with understanding this kind
of the structure of meta-mathematical
space the structure of the space of sort
of all possible mathematical constructs
and this kind of idea that category
theory is the kind of Continuum limit is
the kind of large-scale feature of it's
one of the ways to describe on a large
scale what happens in kind of
metamatmatical space
um seems like a useful kind of way to
think about things
but um
I think that there are there are other
aspects of kind of the the possibility
of doing mathematics
um that uh sort of emerges at a large
scale okay how does this relate to
um to language and um I have to remember
how this all works there was a chap
called uh ajukowitz back in the 1930s
who um long before current ideas about
the construction of language
um due to people like Chomsky and uh the
phrase structure grammars and all of
this kind of pre-structuring grammars
and things that was only really codified
in the in 1956
um there was a much earlier approach to
language that um uh was made that is a
more that that sort of turns into
category Theory
okay how does it work his heart
basically works the um
the normal way of thinking about
language is you you say I'm going to
take a sentence I'm going to break it
down it's got a noun phrase a verb
phrase a noun phrase let's say the noun
phrase breaks down into an article a
determiner an adjective a a a noun and
so on
um the uh
um
and that um uh and that's kind of a a
break things down in this kind of
tree-like way and that's that's how when
you diagram a sentence you're typically
showing this tree-like structure that
sentences have okay so a different idea
is Imagine That words kind of multiply
together so when you say black cat it's
kind of like having black times cat it's
kind of like having a mathematical
expression where there is a um uh where
where you're kind of um combining words
sort of like you combine elements in a
in a in a a multiplication or something
like this so there's a different way of
thinking about how you construct
grammars that is the so-called
categorical grammars
um that are much more along the lines of
you apply functions to words so in
ordinary grammar you know the ordinary
kind of way of doing it with sort of
tree-like grammars you're you're sort of
breaking down the sentence in the way I
described but an alternative would be to
say
um let's take a take the cat construct
and let's sort of multiply in let's
apply the Blackness function to it and
so we have kind of black cat is not
quite a multiplication it's really a
function application to cat we apply the
function black and and then we say you
know
sat on the mat we apply the function sat
to this and then we apply that function
sat has two arguments it has um uh you
know the cat and well oh gosh I should
have had a transitive verb but on the
mat as is the other part of it and um
the uh
uh and so the way that categorical
grammars work is um is this idea of kind
of applying functions to get uh to
construct your sentence so your sentence
becomes a bunch of function applications
and it's also deeply related to
combinators
um now what can you do with this
well
um
okay so these function applications are
like these morphisms I've described in
category Theory and okay the among the
things that happen are
okay so in category Theory you'll have
these objects transformed by morphisms
to other objects and so on you have
these chains of things you also have
these things called functors which are
things that sort of map from one chain
to another chain so one chain might be
an arithmetic and there might be a
functor that maps that to a sort of
corresponding chain in algebra well so
in sentences the analog of a functor
will be something that Maps one sentence
defined by this function thingy which is
like by like morphisms you map that into
a another sentence
so that's kind of an interesting thing
because one of the things I think was
curious about a lot when we were first
building wolfen Alpha is what I call
meaning to meaning to meaning sort of
sentence to sentence Transformations
meaning to meaning Transformations uh
where you would take one sentence and
you would say I've got the sentence
um the cat sat on the mat let's say or
the black cat crossed the road
um and you asked the question how many
different ways can I say that sentence
I'd say that's a really bad example uh
example that we used to use as a test
case for people working on linguistic
curation for Orphan Alpha was how many
ways can you give change for 35 cents
so sort of in that case there are there
are things a little bit like like how
many ways can you make 35 cents out of
coins what uh uh you know what
um
what combination of coins what how many
different combinations of coins make 35
cents those kinds of things there are
many different ways to say essentially
the same thing and that um
[Music]
um
the um uh
okay I think that's actually my I've got
to go and today is a um uh there's a
company holiday day so
um I have slightly different constraints
um
in any case uh what I was just to finish
this one thought the um so this notion
of categorical grammars is this notion
of of grammars in which you're
constructing things by by applying
functions and then there are these
things like transforming one one version
of a sentence to another version of a
sentence which has the same meaning and
one of the things people wonder about is
whether by thinking about grammar in
terms of the application of functions
you can more immediately have something
that represents the meaning of the
sentences it doesn't come for free
that's a separate whole issue of
Designing a computational language the
thing I just spent the last 40 years
doing that has a way of representing
meaning by applying functions that's not
something you magically get by by taking
natural language as it exists and uh and
sort of parsing it in this way whether
you use categorical grammars or any
other kind of grammar that's not that's
not the point the point of of attaching
of kind of representing meaning in a
computational way is a whole separate
set of issues
so in any case that that's um
that's a bit of a story I'm actually
pretty amazed that I managed to do well
I don't know how well I did here but but
um category theory is a pretty obstruse
area and um I at least made an attempt
to explain how it works and categorical
Gammas are even even more abstruse
um I noticed Trev asks what limitations
does wolf malfa currently have and what
methods to expl do you are you exploring
to address those limitations that's a
long story but the one thing that is
very uh unforgiving about operating a
system like Wolfram Alpha is every day
we have a a whole boatload of what we
call fall throughs that is questions
people ask that we couldn't answer and
so that's a very that's a very good we
do a pretty good job if we think we can
answer the question we actually can
answer it we're not sort of guessing oh
statistically we might be able to give
the right answer if we if we think we
know the answer we think we got the
right interpretation of the of the input
language and we think we actually
computed the right answer but but um we
uh
we we have um uh we're pretty confident
of that but nevertheless we can see
every day a set of questions that get
asked that um uh that we couldn't answer
and that is kind of the giant to-do list
so to speak that we have for the last uh
well since 2009 when wolfen Alpha
launched we've been steadily grinding
through all the different kinds of fall
throughs that happen to uh uh to make to
make Wolfram Alpha understand and be
able to compute as much as possible
right I should wrap up there well thanks
for joining me and um
thanks for those questions and I see a
lot of other interesting questions here
and hopefully I'll get to address those
um another time all right bye for now